who's driving
they're over there we're just some of
the people they almost hit like this
okay what happened
um I'm not sure are the subscribers and
they kind of stopped us and they said
that we almost
hit a child I
I said we did
um but that's what they told us
fairly unit on the reckless driver on
Smyrna Dunes
yeah well the people are down here
because you can't drive on this part of
the beach I'm so sorry
you had your license on you yes thank
you
I would get your phone out of there your
car's not going to be moving for a while
okay can I get it yeah go get your
license in your phone
she's gonna go to jail okay
all right so you can go with her or you
can stay out and get her out of jail
with the boss and why am I going
so right now I think you're driving
Under the Influence okay all right
then we got Reckless with multiple
people over here we were inches away
from multiple people okay
[Applause]
yes sorry
what do I do now call the Volusia County
Branch daily gearbone it's not good
still have a bond
bother out